from timcast.com Facebook worked with
the FBI to spy on conservatives who
questioned the 2020 election the company
has been sending direct messages of its
users to the FBI for 19 months oh that's
crazy and of course all of you know
timcast.com is newsguard certified that
means this reporting is true and correct
you see we do not repeatedly publish
false content good for us we clarify
errors we discover we do disclose
ownership so when people ask you how do
you you know the FBI is not spying with
with Facebook's help you can be like
News Guard certified website said it was
true here you go a new report from the
New York Post cites sources from within
the U.S Department of Justice who say
someone at Facebook has red flagged what
are deemed to be subversive private
messages over the past 19 months and
transmitted them to the domestic
terrorism unit at FBI headquarters in DC
the post spoke with multiple individuals
who did not wish to be identified quote
it was done outside the legal process
and without probable cause an anonymous
source said Facebook provides the FBI
with private conversations which are
protected by the First Amendment without
any subpoena according to the report the
private messages are then sent to FBI
field offices around the country as
leads which has resulted in the targeted
Facebook users being investigated
Sometimes using covert surveillance
techniques all of the accounts flagged
for domestic Terror is a more
conservative right-wing individuals
it must be just a mistake you know they
forgot to go after antifa yeah a source
said they were gun toting red-blooded
Americans who were angry after the
election and shooting off their mouths
and talking about staging protests there
was nothing criminal nothing about
violence or massacring or assassinating
anyone as soon as a subpoena as soon as
subpoena was requested within an hour
Facebook sent back gigabytes of data and
photos it was ready to go they were just
waiting for that legal process so they
could send it and I also think too they
say they do mention even before that
without any subpoena so a lot of these
were just Facebook being like here you
go buddy have fun
One Source characterized the operation
as a waste of our time now that's
amazing when confronted over the
allegations Facebook first issued a
denial however an hour later Erica's
second spokesperson at Facebook's parent
company meta said the company was
working with the FBI to protect people
from harm and there it is
these claims are false because they
reflect a misunderstanding on how our
systems protect people from harm and how
we engage with law enforcement we
carefully scrutinize all government
requests blah blah blah these claims are
just wrong the suggestion we seek out
people's private messages for
anti-government language or questions
about the validity of past elections and
then proactively Supply those to the FBI
is plainly inaccurate and there is zero
evidence to support it as of September
14th the FBI would neither confirm or
deny the specific allegation of private
messages being shared by Facebook but
said that the agency maintains
relationships with social media
companies the FBI also said it maintains
an ongoing dialogue with social media
platforms to enable a quick exchange of
threat information
so signal do you guys use signal what do
you use you don't want to tell people
what you use uh first of all because
there's a lot of different platforms up
there some of them are even honey pots I
don't think there's anything sacred
there's there's no privacy online
whenever you have an iPhone or an
Android or you're on Facebook everything
you say is going directly to them and
the feds and I just wanted to comment
here there sure seems to be a lot of
connections to Intel agencies and
Facebook especially since the beginning
of that company and even yesterday Our
Guest Devin Nunes I asked him who's more
powerful big Tech social media or the
intelligence agencies he said that
they're the same thing and they are but
but the funny thing was that he was like
that's a good question yes and he
thought about it and then he talked
about something else and I'm like wait
hold on and then I had to ask him again
and he was like they're the same thing
and they are they absolutely are and I
want to make this point and we talk
about this in the conspiracy world and
Timmy said a funny thing about how I'm
kind of like Luke's progeny and I am
because Luke has been well that was
before the show so nobody knows the
comments I know but if Luke is you know
an OG truther but we'll get into that
but I just want to make this point too
is we have what is known as Declassified
information called operation Mockingbird
and this is in the 70s and this is when
the CIA said that they have represented
representatives in every form of our
media radio television movies and films
that was the church committee hearings
yeah specifically operation Mockingbird
was it was a different operation just a
heads up there's like a little misnomer
okay well listen he's an expert he's a
nerd I'm primetime
my point being is that we know that they
have representatives in all of these
platforms so if you don't think that
social media is not infected with
representatives from the FBI and CIA
you're dreaming and that is why Tick
Tock is so dangerous because Tick Tock
has representatives from the Chinese
government and now they have all of our
information of little kids and Lord
knows these kids are very vulnerable on
there so who knows what what information
they have on them what pictures so
that's all of these social media
platforms that we use that are fully
addicting are basically all DARPA
engineered social media addiction tools
to get inside information about
ourselves Twitter uh whistleblower
recently revealed that there were I
think foreign spies in Twitter and that
I think what they said was well if we've
got one then who cares if there are more
let's recruit more people and wasn't the
Saudi government caught spying on
activists that were protesting them and
getting data and information about that
I have to fact check the story the Saudi
Prince buy a portion of it exactly we
cannot talk about Saudi Arabia without
mentioning the 19 hijackers that uh uh
oh I don't want to know We're not gonna
do that no I'm just kidding because
Luke's on the show so right now but we
love soccer we're gonna go off the rails
we got this model I like that Alex is
here
we love you Saudi right now
the members only segment tonight will be
watch the members only we're gonna go
insane for the Ukraine
how you doing Ryan
I'm sorry I wasn't sure what what Alex
how hard he was gonna come in but he's
coming very hard I mean right I mean
he's like the Kool-Aid man busting out
of the wall over there but yeah I mean
you know it is it is fascinating though
you know we you hear slippery slope it's
really not a slope it's a cliff I mean
we you look at Facebook and social media
we talk about censorship but this is
this is well beyond that and what we're
going to see now is basically this
database this information that is going
to be used against anybody who is
remotely conservative and you know I'm
obviously working with kids thinking
about the future thinking about
education
anything you've ever said anything
you've ever done will be taken
misconstrued and in waiting for the day
that you decide to speak up speak out
you're targeted you have an
investigation into you and you know I
mean at this point they are building
basically and off of Oppo file and
anybody who ever remotely is going to do
anything outside the uh the status quo
there when you have we got to stop the
cult man that it's it's it's remarkable
people fearing fearing the cult is why
cancel culture works if there was an
opportunity for people to live and work
outside of whatever those institutions
are then no one would care they'd be
like oh you said this five years ago
they'd be like okay great what's that
gonna mean that's right because in the
real world that that does not impact you
until you allow like you said basically
those forces to say you know what
actually a lot of people blew us up on
Facebook today so actually we are going
to fire you or actually we are going to
do this now but if you actually just go
around and just actually communicate
with folks and you actually talk to real
people like you guys were talking about
earlier when we're up there but but are
these actually even real users I mean
are these even real people that are that
are stirring up a lot of this and you
don't even know but that's what ends up
happening it's it's beyond just the cult
because if you look at big Tech social
media they control the commons they
control the information highways they
control what could what people think
Facebook was manipulating people's
emotions Facebook Mark Zuckerberg
literally spent 419 million dollars
ahead of the 2020 elections in order to
fortify it specifically in major
Democratic areas to make sure that
people came out and voted against Donald
Trump Mark Zuckerberg participated
worked with the FBI to censor the hunter
Biden laptop story a story that
according to many political experts
swayed the elections in favor of Joe
Biden clearly Joe Biden is the president
of the intelligence agency he has been
doing their biddings the the social
media companies are not there to be
social media companies they're there to
be the long arm of the big text of of
the intelligence agencies let's also
remember uh Facebook was experimenting
on people yeah we've mentioned this
several times the past week that they
this they they were experimenting people
putting depressing information in their
feed to see how they respond and sure
enough people started getting depressed
they would post depressing things the
same thing was too with positive stuff
we know about that what else do you
think they've done you don't do like I
got to tell you I'm I'm I when they
censor information
it's Overton in our face we see it
happening but I have to imagine this
there's a lot of censorship you don't
see at all we know about Shadow Banning
like we talked about it in the beginning
of the show that people are saying the
link to the to Tim Castile isn't working
that the notifications aren't going out
and then I'm like well who knows what's
happening then I go to our own website
and our own Auto embed feature stopped
working around the exact same time that
so that that's got to be something
there's censorship you can't see but
when it comes to the news feed on
Facebook that's where it gets real dark
because that's totally algorithmic
they're choosing what you do see it's
like not just censorship it's curation
as well so they can make you believe
whatever they want by inundating you and
they're so and gaslighting you and
gaslighting I think one of the things
that's happening is people like us and
the people listen to this show will seek
out something here's the example if
YouTube is not sending out the
notification for this show and people
have pointed that out that means the
people listening chose to come here they
searched for it and they tried to find
it these are people who are
substantially more likely to seek out
information on news events
no it's no wonder these people you know
agree with us on a lot of issues then
you look at the people who aren't
willing to do that they sit in front of
their Facebook they see a headline and
they go and then they keep scrolling and
they believe it and that's what
entrenches the cult
I just want to make this point I think I
said this last time on the show Andrew
Breitbart said that in the future we're
gonna have to have internet ghettos and
that's basically where we're at now
that's what you have to have these like
little uh you know your own paywall or
your own platform and that's why I like
but it never works true social is Never
Gonna never gonna be as good as Twitter
so it's it's kind of future I would I
would say yes to a point on that with
true social but the engagement on true
social is actually fairly yeah it's not
a nothing Burger but it's just not the
same it's never going to be the same
there's a reason why you like the ease
of YouTube because the chat is just
efficient or you just you know just
whatever's familiar to you I think I
think that the main issue is only the
most Ardent diehards for the most part
go to platforms like truth or Rumble
yeah we use Rumble infrastructure and we
do post to rumble but when you're trying
to reach independent voters and normies
you know you've got to be on the
platforms wherever we've got to fish
where the fish are as the same goes
yeah and I mean and what you've seen is
they had control of Legacy Media then I
was talking to you guys about this you
know it's funny because my background in
education you know they all you know the
conventional wisdom is kids you know
they can't pay attention for more than
20 minutes of a Time learning needs to
look like this and what do you know the
most digested form of media amongst
young people are podcasts like yours
this long form let's do deep Dives they
they love it they love the challenging
of of you know conventional wisdom let's
talk through this let's do a deep dive
let's investigate this stuff they will
go along with that but now guess what
the left says well we control Legacy
Media
well we've got to make sure that these
folks aren't able to get to more people
so now we've got a I mean it's a
constant game of control obviously but
it also shows that now they know Legacy
Media is dying newspaper industry is
dying so now we've got to control the
podcast because again I I mean I I come
back to this Ground Zero is our is the
war on our young people because the
reality is if they can control them and
to your point Tim if they control the
entire narrative and that's what most of
them see the only people that are gonna
be able to find the information of the
true the truth Seekers and the people
will only go above and beyond to do that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there